your money is lazy if your money was
employees you would fire your money you
do not have money because you're
spending your money on the things that
are not working and generating money
back for you the only thing that matters
is a free cash flow that's it
rise and shine
it's an espresso time what's up believe
nation it's Evan I believe in you and
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine so let's
start your day off right together grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
get your money to work over to you grant
cardone also if you want to know what
grant and other successful entrepreneurs
have to say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my to 54 series or
every day for the next 254 days I will
send you a morning video for free to
help you build your confidence the link
to join is in the description below you
have to go build self-confidence you
don't have more money folks because nice
not it's not because you don't work it's
not because you're not a good person
it's not because you overspend it's not
because you've got too much debt it's
not because you don't bust your ass it's
because your money doesn't bust its ass
your money is lazy if your money was
employees you would fire your money so
here's the rules okay number one the the
money the extra money should go into
something that gives you money you want
your money to have babies the Golden
Goose is no law no longer good if she
doesn't have eggs the only thing that
makes the Golden Goose valuable is the
fact that the Golden Goose waves legs
lays eggs so if you just study the
wealthiest families in the world not
just in America in the world over long
periods of time look at the Queen the
Queen of England this much property and
one of the richest families in the world
why they get cash flow every month from
India from England from Ireland from all
over the world while the princes in
arabia's so wealthy because they have
constant inflow of money coming from the
land that produces the oil the oil comes
out of the land and produces cash flow
the railroads the railroads back in the
day what they do they got all this land
together and then they rented that land
out to everybody around it why do all
the teachers credit unions take all the
money from all the teachers around
America and then they start investing in
real estate that produces cash flow so
they can distribute back to their
members I'm always going to come back to
this one story look real assets that
produce real cash flow every month when
it pays you every month and you're
getting reminded every month I got a
check I got a little hundred dollar
check I got a two hundred dollar check
this month I got a thirteen thousand
dollar check today from one of my
properties every month I get a check for
thirteen grand from that property it's
one hundred and fifty thousand dollars a
year it didn't start like that it used
to be like 1,300 bucks 1,300 then it was
26 then it was 5,000 next thing you know
it's 13 grand that's one property pays
me every month property just sits there
okay just sits there it might not even
change in value just sits there and
produces cash flow anything that
produced this cash flow will be worth
more money tomorrow
that's why Netflix is valuable why
because people pay a lot of cash into
Netflix and even if Netflix loses money
today some company will find Netflix
desirable for one reason cash flow is
king I hate spending money till I'm
making money if you do not have money
it's because you are spending your money
on things that are not making you money
this is what happens in so many
entrepreneurs businesses when you're
starting you go and you spend a whole
bunch of money on different gear
equipment samples products and then it
doesn't work out instead of going out
and spending money at the start find a
way to get started on the cheap
investing your energy your hustle your
drive your initiative but not your money
here's what happens someone wants to
start a t-shirt business okay great
to get the price discounts that you want
to that on a per t-shirt basis it's
cheaper you have to order 5,000 t-shirts
so you go out and you spend all your
money ordering 5,000 t-shirts or worse
you go take a loan so you can get your
5,000 t-shirts
the t-shirts come in you sell three of
them and then you have 4,997 t-shirts
sitting in your mom's basement that's
most people you'll spend money because
you've got this ambitious dream you
envision you've seen your head outs all
gonna work out but then when you get
started it never works out if you think
it's gonna work out when I first said it
on YouTube I had a team of eight or so
people already in my other business in
my main business and so I'm gonna try
this thing on the side just as a fun
thing and see how it goes I did
everything myself myself I did
everything myself invest my energy my
heart my hustle my drive my intuition
into making something happen and once I
started making some money then I could
invest into building a team into getting
gear into building this business up so
now we've got 24 people on the team when
I first started doing my Instagram live
morning shows it was me and my tripod
and a cell phone and a guest and we went
live on Instagram every day and then
people said hey you should get a
microphone okay great I got a quick
little microphone that connected and we
went now this thing might be the future
that may be all I do I might even close
down YouTube and just do Instagram lives
and if that happens and I'll invest in
the team and making that happen maybe in
three years if I'm still doing it
there'll be 20 people in the room from a
producer and camera people and editors
and everybody's in the room guiding the
show right that might be the future but
I don't know I got to start by just
doing one show you do not have money
because you're spending your money on
the things that are not working and
generating money back for you so stop
spending money
stop stop it right now stop spending
money on things that don't make you
money instead invest your energy your
hustle your time your drive as a default
until you're making a little bit of
money from that thing a little bit of
money from that thing and then you can
invest that money to make more money so
let's take the t-shirt companies an
example and set up going out and buying
5,000 t-shirts you buy 0 and you upload
your design to one of the t-shirt
on-demand services now you're gonna make
less money per t-shirt great but your
first 5 to 10 designs may not work out
and this is your chance to test it so
even though you're making less
per t-shirt you're actually making cash
flow right you're making a profit you
have money coming in even though it's
not as much as you want but you can test
your designs in a zero risk environment
and then when you find the design that's
popping that's hitting hard and you're
building your brand and you're getting
customers then you could take it off of
the print on demand service then you can
go and buy the thousand shirts the five
thousand shirts the ten thousand shirts
because you know it works because you
know it's gonna sell that's how you want
to do it to teach you clean so stop
spending money until you're making money
whatever big dream and Bish's goal you
have I love it it's amazing yes keep to
it and then find the smallest possible
way to get started take that big goal
and chunk it down into the smallest
possible thing that you can do right now
ASAP to start progress to start building
momentum you want to sell a YouTube
channel amazing go right now you don't
need to have fancy gear or lights or
microphone or equipment you don't have
any of that stuff just start take your
phone record a video upload it start
build momentum get better start making a
little bit of money take that money
invest it back in your business your
money invested properly will help you
grow now I've got a really special bonus
script that I think you're gonna enjoy
but before that question of the day I
want to know where do you need to stop
spending money until you're making it
let me know in the comments below what's
the value of a stalk that never returns
capital to its shareholders I don't know
because the only way you can make money
is if somebody else is willing to buy
that position at a higher price for some
emotional reason perhaps or for some you
know foresight that maybe the company
will return capital one day and I think
of you know what when you learn as an
investor over multiple decades is the
only thing that matters is free cash
flow that's it there is no other reason
to own a stock and with that philosophy
it brings you into a place where you
focus on a company's ability to generate
incremental cash flow because just
owning a dividend paying stock is not
good enough because you know let's say
we find a stock today that's paying a
three percent dividend yield and
tomorrow because
it's forecast for sales get cut in half
the stock drops on 50 percent now it's
yielding six percent I don't want to own
that stock either so my tests in this
index that I've you know created with
what see Russell looks at the balance
sheet every year we test to make sure
that the company is viable in its
ability to generate cash this is
extremely conservative investing this is
for the long haul
these tools are not for as you're
suggesting for spicy you know the hot
stock does your I've done that I've been
there you know let the young legs do I
have zero interest in that I don't care
what the hot new stock is you know when
a company comes public I won't own it
either it's got to prove to me over
multiple years that it can continue to
generate cash before it even fits in to
what I'm doing so I'm really boring and
I like it that way so a great company
doesn't necessarily have to equal a
great stock they can be two very
different things from your perspective
there's many companies where I buy their
products and services I would never
touch their stock so you know it's sort
of we're talking about real money here
the stuff that you need to preserve you
know when I think about my family trusts
I can't afford to mess around with that
if you want more grant cardone took at
the top fifty rules video made on him
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there don't
watch the news decide when you leave
here today to make the news dude you
don't get attention today you have
absolutely zero chance of being
successful